The attack on our rights is shocking.
And it's the social consequences of this are unspeakable really. Um,
I mean, people are not going to comply. They're not compliant now.
I'm sure you know, this, in fact you've probably attended them,
but there are speakeasies and all over in New York city popping up, uh,
where you can go to dinner and gathering more than five, more than 10,
even 30 people, you know, and, and they're drinking,
they're having dinner together. They're, they're in defiance of the law. Um, uh,
friends of mine in Manhattan, sit in their penthouses and,
and every night at, uh,
after nightfall people rush out into the streets with noisemakers, uh, just to,
just to illustrate that they believe in freedom.
That's great.
Interesting to me that you use this word, uh, right.
You've been using this repeated our right to assemble a right to such
a right to speak a right is not something that's contingent.
It's something that you actually possess.
It's not granted to you by the government.
It's something you owned by virtue of each humanity.
It's hard to talk about rights, uh, in these times.
And we don't apparently have the right to our own property because the
government can shut down our business on grounds that it's unessential. Right.
Uh, we probably don't have the right even to leave our
homes, um, that,
so once you take that away, I mean, they've,
I don't want to be alarmist about this or anything,
but look from a philosophical point of view,
we are living the practical reality of what comes very
close to be in a totalitarian state right now. Um, now,
uh, fortunately thank you, political leaders,
you're letting the grocery stores work. Fortunately, they're private, you know,
uh, uh, uh, thank you for letting us have pharmacies. You know, they're,
they're private entities too. Um,
so we're grateful for the little bit of private, private, private,
private markets that are left, but,
but the attack on everybody else and the attack on our rights is shocking.
And it's the social consequences of this are unspeakable really. Um,
I mean, people are not going to comply. They're not compliant now.
I'm sure you know, this, in fact you've probably attended them,
but there are speakeasies and all over in New York city popping up, uh,
where did you can go to dinner and gathering more than five, more than 10,
even 30 people, you know, and, and they're drinking,
they're having dinner together. They're there in defiance of the law. Um, uh,
friends of mine in Manhattan sit in their penthouses and,
and every night at, uh,
after nightfall people rush out into the streets with noisemakers, uh, just to,
just to illustrate that they believe in freedom, you know, and for God's sake,
do, are we not, do we not believe in freedom anymore?
The politicians presume that we're, we're, we're like pieces on a chess board.
They can just move around, but you know what? That's not true.
That is not the human mind. We are not inanimate objects.
We're not birds in cages. We will live free one way or the other.
So what would you say? So of course I'm with you,
but what would you say to the people that would say, but all of those people,
your friends that are going out onto the streets at night and the people that
are getting together at speakeasies and going out more than they have to go out
and the rest of it and exercising their rights and freedom,
that those are the people who are going to keep this thing spreading,
because people don't know what,
when to reign in their own personal responsibility and,
and do something so that, you know, society doesn't crumble,
something like that.
Well, I, I, you know, at, at the, at the, at the head end of the light,
you know, wherever you discovered this idea of human freedom,
there was also disease.
If we didn't have very clean water, uh, the, you know, th there were, uh,
annual viruses that came along and killed people,
and there were pandemics and so on,
but they still somehow came to believe that human beings have the
right to speak and associated and trade, and we work around it. And, and,
and part of the belief in freedom is the confidence that society has the
intelligence to deal with things like viruses that come along and the
existence of disease does not disable, uh,
the whole of modernity. It just doesn't,
we can't think this way maternity was for time.
And there was this, and even back to the black death,
then invent venison. And, uh, in the third to 13th century, when it was,
there was still interest, they still kept trade going. There was, there was,
there was some towns would come up with the restrictions and that sort of thing.
But, um, but the idea of violating people's rights,
fundamental rights to live and choose and speak,
and everything was even thinkable 500 years ago. I mean, the,
our response we've done here is it's, pre-modern,
it's medieval, it's, it's, it's 11th and 12th century style stuff,
except with a 21st century technology. Uh,
and we're not responding to the things scientifically, even, even,
even the slightest bit, uh, the response by the political class. And I mean,
from about March 15th,
onward was nothing short of mystical, superstitious.
Uh, it was a panic response. Let's just, uh,
let's just throw everybody in a cage of their own creation and,
and punish anybody for coming out of it. And I, I, I just,
I totally forgive people who are going through these speakeasies. And may,
you could say that prudent, you know, they shouldn't be doing that,
but for God's sake, people exercising their fundamental rights.
I'd say we need more of that. Not of that right now.
Do you think that's,
that's partly just human nature that so many people just operate purely in fear.
So, you know,
like a month ago when we had that two day window where suddenly everything shut
down out of nowhere, you know,
they announced the entire NBA season was canceled,
and then they canceled all these public events and,
and everything sort of happened at within a two day thing that there becomes
this odd rush to cancel,
because you don't want to be the one guy who's going against the crowd, right?
You don't want to be the one guy who says, no,
we're not going to cancel our season.
We're not going to cancel all of our things.
We're going to wait it out a little bit,
knowing that the risk that you take of being just destroyed by the media and
everything else on the other side is probably worse than just going along with,
with, with the crowd, with the wave.
Yeah. I understand your point.
I have my doubts that there was any public support for this, uh,
actually at all. Now it's entirely up to private venues,
whether or not they want to have these gatherings or to accept the liability
associated with NBA games or, or South by Southwest, you know,
and that sort of thing, Southwest Southwestern chooses, uh,
to cancel a conference that was a governmental decision. So I'm looking at this,
and I'm not saying whether that was maybe South by Southwest,
should've canceled. You know, I don't know. I think about this a lot.
I'm not actually sure about that.
Cause that's mostly all young people there who are actually not, uh,
in any great danger from COVID. Um, so I'm not, I'm not sure about that.
And it's hard to do counterfactuals here, but with this much, um, uh, Dave,
I know, and I think, you know, to, um,
politicians prioritizing governors, mayors, um,
senators and congressmen and so on and not owners of anything,
their main job is to get back to it again, that's it.
So they don't really have a financial economic stake.
They don't have skin in the game, apart from the desire to get voters,
to vote for them again.
And there was a sudden panic on the part of political leaders at all levels,
really, um, that if anybody died while they were in office,
that they would somehow be, uh, uh, blamed for this, unless,
unless they just bludgeoned people, you know, and, and ruin people's lives.
So they somehow believed there was less risk to steal people's property and
arrest people in their homes, uh, uh, than it was to, to, to, um,
to be blamed for, uh, pro public death. And, and that,
that gets us back to a problem, regardless,
discussion the role of the media here,
because what they're really fearing ultimately is is,
is this cancel culture, you know, the, the Twitter mops and, and, uh,
and the New York times editorial page and, and, and, and the media culture,
that's this last lost all rationality and clearly clarity there.
They're afraid of being, um, uh, denounced and dragged through the mud and,
and drawn and quartered and so on by the press. So I ultimately,
I feel like storm to you, doesn't that feel? Yeah.
And storm of just of the end of the media that we've all been seeing.
And as you said before, you didn't even want to see it,
but that's so many of us have seen the end of mainstream media.
We've watched our academic and political institutions crumble,
and then something like this comes in and just takes the last remaining
foundation of it, and then adds fear to it.
And you take just fearful people who don't even understand what their rights are
as you alluded to earlier. And then you really have, have the perfect storm to.
To control everybody. But I like this phrase, the perfect storm,
and I think it's the best description to explain what's happened to us. Really.
It wasn't, it wasn't really a conspiracy and, uh, uh, from the top,
but of course, you know, there's conspiracy theories was like,
we'll never stop them. You know, they've been generated by the day.
And I totally forgive that.
People want it want to understand what has happened to their freedoms.
What's happened to their rights,
but why did the world go dark suddenly then people assume there's some central
plan. I don't believe that actually.
I think it was just this combination of fact.
And I I've been wanting to kind of write about this for a while, but yeah,
it is a perfect storm. It was, uh, uh, Holly media, panic politicians,
um, and just as onslaught, you know,
combined with a lack of information,
but I've described an epidemic crisis that led to a complete panic,
but we're going to be,
we're going to be spending the next 10 years trying to figure this out.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.